for those as far as you can can I mean
do whatever you need to do for 45
seconds Prince William and Kate
Middleton go head to head in a spin
class William has never been more
confident more happy but that confidence
led the Prince of Wales to a little
wardrobe mishap
it all went down during the couple's
visit to a fitness center in South Wales
where they took part in a virtual
endurance Challenge and things got
competitive fast
bring up
first let's point out Kate and William
aren't really dressed for the occasion
both rocking business casual Chic but
even cycling in a skirt couldn't stop
the princess from taking home the top
prize so the winner of today's sports
it's bike number two
foreign
as she turns 40 it seems that Kate's
more willing to let her guard down a bit
and show us a bit more of the real Kate
but Prince William didn't go home
empty-handed he's the proud recipient of
some ripped hands
he's married very happily married he's
got someone who is a supportive partner
but also willing to share the work
clothes will absolutely be the decade
we're going to see him lay down the
foundation of a future king Williams
still got years before he's head of the
British Monarchy following Queen
Elizabeth's death the royal family is
now preparing for his father King
Charles's coronation I think that's what
we're going to see as as he leads up to
his coronation date how is he prepping
well this is a moment he spent his life
preparing for I think more importantly
than prepping we're seeing him hitting
the ground running with his work putting
down those markers as king and really
not letting any time go to waste putting
the focus on the things that matter to
him as Charles takes on his role as King
William will be there right by his side
but I think William recognizes that his
father can through age alone only really
be transitional King the future of the
monarchy the future of the House of
Windsor very much on William's shoulders
it was something he struggled with as a
Young Man work-life balance which
Birmingham he's really English to stride
I think he feels optimistic about the
future and I think in terms of the
future of the monarchy William is spoky
two women
[Music]